spencer you have a quote on your
linkedin profile one question i
constantly ask myself when crafting a
film is this what is the deepest place i
can write from
yeah i mean that's that's the question
you need to ask yourself when you're
writing
if you want something to really connect
with people you got to dig deep because
you can't expect the audience to feel
the same emotions when they watch it on
screen if you don't first go through
those same emotions in the writing
process
do you ever feel like
maybe i should reign it in it's too much
or do you always err on the side of
actually no i want someone to feel
exactly what i'm feeling so i don't mind
if it just
bleeds all over the page put it all out
there i mean why not you know
like
i i think some of my heroes have done
that and that's why
that's why i'm um pushed to do the same
thing to push myself to be more
vulnerable because the most yeah the
most um impactful um pieces of art that
i've ever um you know seen or heard or
consumed are the ones that are the most
honest and the most vulnerable um and so
there's an album called the color clear
by reflections and that whole album the
first time i heard it i was just mind
blown with just how personal the whole
thing was
and
i was just shocked at how much i related
to all of it and how many of the
how much of the experiences that that
vocalist jake wolf went through that
were similar to mine
and um when i heard that and and there's
been other ones too of course but like
just that one for example um
it really opened uh it just opened the
world to me and it made it uh it made me
feel comforted it made me feel less
alone and so i wanted to do the same for
others
is that a a metal band or a funk okay
yeah they're great they're based here in
l.a no they're in minnesota oh wow and i
actually got to fly out to minnesota and
interview the vocalist on my podcast and
it was it was a dream come true and it
was we had a really great time talking
about um just personal pain and putting
putting the pain onto the page you know
and that is that is what connects with
people and that's why people love
his band and that's why people love
space waves
you know when you're honest out there it
just it can't help but resonate and
connect with people so you were a fan of
the band first and then you reached out
to them you said wow
that's a cool opportunity oh yeah it was
amazing and he's a great guy i flew out
to minnesota for their like reunion show
because they were on hiatus for a while
so i flew out there and then he was a
super cool guy he invited me into his
home and we got to record a podcast got
to talk to him for like two and a half
hours um and so he's one of my heroes
and so that was an amazing experience
but your movie space waves is is lighter
in terms of what you see in the trailer
but you wanted to make it where
at the core it was actually much heavier
right i mean it's not yeah yeah i mean
it is it is a
it's a kind of a balance between that
comedy and drama like i said and so it's
um
on the surface it's just a comedy but if
you are watching it with attentive eyes
and you
um connect with the characters
then it is something much deeper you
know and that second half of the film
resonates much more
and so i think i think we pulled it off
with like with a really good ending and
there still is there still is comedy and
fun in the second half of the movie but
it just looks a little bit different and
so
um that's just how life is when you grow
up you know you're still you're still
able to have fun but it just looks
different than when you were in high
school riding around in shopping carts
and shooting people with paintballs and
stuff um so it's just it's just
different
how was to recreate some of the painful
scenes for you in the film
uh it was
very difficult um
specifically the argument scene and then
the dvd handoff scene in space waves um
those were they're very they i don't
know they were just hard to be in that
moment on set because it felt like i was
back in that moment you know back in
high school going through that same
friendship breakup or going through the
moment where um the dvd handoff at the
end where they're trying to like repair
the friendship a little bit
um and so it yeah it was emotional and
it was emotional for
uh
i would say everyone involved um
and andrew gabriel and rudy pankow
our two leads were they're friends in
real life and so at the time of filming
space waves it was very raw and
emotional for them as well because here
they are they they went to the same
acting class when when they first got to
la and so they're super close then
they're doing this movie together and
they're doing a movie about them
breaking up and going separate ways and
not being you know as close of friends
anymore and so it was tough for them as
well to kind of go through this and you
know play pretend that their friendship
is ending
so it was it was emotional for them it
was it was emotional for me um but i
think i think
that's how it should be you know it's
emotional on set and then it's going to
be emotional on screen when people see
it later
did you receive notes back from viewers
that their chemistry was great that
seemed very true yeah definitely um i
think people could see that there was
chemistry there and that they're
actually friends in real life
do you care more about the emotional
impact of a scene
or is making an entertaining movie
the goal
um
why do we have to choose how about it's
both
i would say it has i mean it has to be
both it ha yeah it has to be both um
but yeah i mean just make it i say i
mean make it as emotional and moving as
possible and make it as entertaining and
fun as possible as well i mean those two
things aren't mutually exclusive so i
try to do it i try to push it to the
limit in every aspect of filmmaking you
know whether that be the acting or the
edit or the sound design you know every
element of filmmaking is there to
elevate the story and to make it the
most emotionally impacting as possible
and make it the most entertaining fun
wild ride as possible
and is darkness bad
no
we all have it so everyone can relate to
it
what about those that don't want to
acknowledge darkness
they're living in a fantasy land um i
think
if you just walk around
i mean there's something to trying to be
positive right and that's that's great
but when i think you can be
optimistic to a fault because sometimes
i think there's a lot of truth in the
rubble and you can learn a lot about
yourself and about others and about
human nature when you examine the uglier
parts of yourself and about humanity and
everything and i think that's where the
real i think that's where the real
growth happens
was there a turning point in the writing
process for the screenplay where you
couldn't turn back like were you maybe
on the fence in the beginning or not no
or never okay
spencer's never on the fence no i get
very obsessed with my ideas and it was
just yeah it was all i thought about for
the whole summer and just one and from
then on out it was like gotta make this
film so
where were you writing it
um i was writing it just down here in
socal where i live
so in college in between classes or you
said it's summers yeah yeah it was a
break yeah i mean just summer break and
then also just you know we i i i revised
it over the whole year because we we had
a summer and i wrote the film and then
we went the whole year doing
pre-production and so i was just kind of
revising it that whole time and then we
went and shot it summer 2018.
reflecting on it now what were the most
important parts of the screenwriting
process for space waves
so some of the most important parts of
the screenwriting process would be
the dialogue and so i wanted to really
make sure that the dialogue reflected
real life
and i wanted to incorporate a lot of the
jokes that me and my friends or my
friends and i would say to each other
and so
i tried to put a lot of inside jokes
into the film and a lot of just
um
a lot of things that like an audience
watching they might not necessarily
understand what the joke is or whatever
but they're laughing along with it
because they see that like oh this is
just something that the characters have
between each other and it builds history
and it builds out the world
when the characters have their own
inside jokes and things like that um and
another part of the screenwriting
process was i really tried to i yeah i
really tried to expand the world i tried
to build the world out so whether that
be creating these um you know these fake
podcasts that are that are going by on
the podcast charts or um we have this
kind of running gag in the film about
where's ruth and so we had like the the
news ticker going across being like this
missing person ruth blah blah and then
in the newspaper it's like where's ruth
and like we just came up with all these
funny little easter eggs and things that
like built the world out and so
that was very important to me was just
making this world feel very lived in and
feel very real and feel a bit larger
than life